agora você faz é essa casa a casa a casa
em casa não quer fazer mal a ninguém que
eu aprenda a fazer
ai ai ai ai
i
ai ai ai ai ai ai ai
a natureza grande manhã em essência ou
sumir na minha vida eu senti ao cense a
um consagrado sentir que quem havia
adquirido ou essa conexão com a natureza
e na verdade vim com mais para saber
encontrar isso
é
ae
ai ai
hoje eu quero falar de uma história uma
história pra vocês eu quero contar um
pouco da história de uma xamã é como
vocês viram no vídeo aquela que faz
parte dessa história é o movimento é
movimento onde existe uma escola chamou
há muitos anos quando ela se isso foi
muito tempo
há muitos anos eu trouxe comigo das
estrelas alguns ensinamentos investir
nessa terra e esse destino envolve a
escutar as pessoas envolvidas
compreender a natureza envolve a
compreender reservas envolvia me
envolver completamente com a cura a cura
quando eu falo a cura em termos amplos
não há cura física mas a cura através de
uma consciência onde as pessoas se dão
conta daquilo que existe em si nos seus
sintomas e o significado do que existe
porque que isso existe
e nesse sentido foi crescendo tendo
minhas visões aprendendo a conviver com
o invisível aprendendo também há a
compreender que os adultos não entendiam
muito a linguagem que eu trazia é que a
linguagem de ver seres a linguagem
conviver com coisas que não muitas
pessoas não dão o menor valor possível
evitar já tem uma profunda fazia nesse
mundo foi criada nesse mundo eu fui eu
vivi minha infância e retira a honra de
ter uma uma doença que me deixava sem
sem poder brincar muito com as crianças
fora que foi a asma e que me deixou
praticamente sozinha durante sete anos
da minha vida no processo de hoje eu
entendo é como se fosse uma busca da
visão
hoje eu entendo que é um processo
xamânico também onde as pessoas precisam
viver consigo para compreender a si
própria compreender o universo
e assim eu fui crescendo fui afirmando o
meu propósito é mesmo a minha alma nunca
me deixou me desviar no meu caminho e
pra isso eu tive que fazer
muitas experiências até que cheguei num
grande movimento que é um movimento que
hoje eu faço parte de um movimento que
fez 24 anos que o movimento terra mirim
onde nós trabalhamos com muitas pessoas
ou trabalhamos com um independente de
raça religião de cor
essas coisas todas ou de gênero então a
gente trabalha com as pessoas eu
particularmente trabalho com as pessoas
tanto aqui no brasil quanto no exterior
e hoje eu sinto que cada vez mais nós
não estamos ultrapassando determinados
preconceitos e conceitos criados pela
sociedade pelo sistema e não nos deixa é
voar que não nos deixa que nos impede de
ser aquilo que realmente somos
ou seja que não deixem desenvolver
nossas reais talentos
então o que eu faço mais hoje é tocar as
pessoas seus próprios talentos para que
elas possam se libertar e essa liberdade
ela vem desde o ponto de vista físico ou
seja você come aquilo que você acredita
você cuida da mãe terra que é básico da
nossa casa e normalmente as pessoas
dizem se qualificam os valorizam a terra
é o de tudo nos é dado não é uma mãe é
uma mãe esse planeta uma mãe então as
pessoas não têm essa visão tão profunda
da terra
então a gente lá eu ensino praticamente
as pessoas a resgatar o respeito pela
terra a resgatarem a casa que elas estão
nós estamos aqui de passagem isso não é
uma coisa mystical mítica é uma
realidade é não pertencermos à terra
nós somos apenas passageiros dessa
pressa terra nesse dia a gente aprender
então a terra além da terra respeito
muito dentro desse processo chamado que
eu vivo os quatro elementos que o ar que
nos inspira faz parte também da nossa
respiração é o soco que nos dá vida à
sexualidade plena a existência aquilo
que a gente realmente se cria dentro de
nós mesmos ea água que são nossas
emoções
por eu ter talvez um processo acadêmico
da psicologia eu dou muita faço muita é
referência aos processos psicológicos
porque eu vejo que cada vez mais a nossa
psique ela cria ela cria as doenças
ela cria os sintomas ela cria as dores
então sempre digo assim se nós temos o
poder de criar porque não de se criar
porque não exercitar também o poder da
descrição do tudo o que é ensinado tudo
o que é passado dessa escola é o poder
da criação e da descrição que você
confiar em você planeja pôr fim à nato a
aliança e confiar nesse átomo do cosmos
é feita gerado
nós somos os série de átomos condensados
nós somos matéria aparentemente mas na
verdade nós somos energia pura gente
pulsa de pontos e e nesse movimento
esses átomos eles dançam e na dança
existe
os espaços onde a gente coloca nossa
doença ou nossa cura
muita gente coloca aquele que a gente
cria e o que a gente diz criar o
importante é que você entre perceba sua
consciência seu sistema interior porque
normalmente não estão totalmente presos
ao sistema estreou aquilo que nos dita
as ordens
aquilo que nos dita as leis mas que leis
são essas que eles fazem parte de mim
para me dizer onde eu devo ir o que eu
devo fazer o que eu devo comer eleição
essas porque se submete essa manipulação
exagerada onde as pessoas dizem onde
tudo os meios de comunicação nos obrigam
praticamente a ser aquilo que a gente
não é
então dentro disso o que o tempo passar
o que o ensino é a gente ser aquilo que
a gente é
nós temos passado nós somos nós somos
seres que voamos por que a gente não
jogou o que nos impede de voar
o que impede de acreditar no nosso sonho
acreditar no sonho é acreditar em você
mesmo é acreditar no cosmos de onde você
veio da sua realidade de uma realidade
onde você faz um pacto você tem um
destino com essa história tá reina
você veio fazer alguma coisa que eu tô
falando de religião
eu tô falando de uma religião significa
carregar
já a ligar com você mesmo mas eu não tô
falando de nenhuma instituição porque se
a gente perceber de verdade toda a
instituição o que ela faz é nos
aprisionar ela vem com outras leis
novamente para que você não possa ser
aquilo que você e nós temos que reais
nos libertarmos de tudo aquilo que nos
aprisiona e poder voar então nesse
sentido a gente tem um eu faço parte
desse movimento que já falei integre
como vocês já viram no vídeo
e aqui gostaria de mostrar algumas
coisas pra vocês por exemplo aqui é o
nosso tempo tempo de meditação porque
sem meditação e sentar em contato com a
profundidade com a nossa espiritualidade
a gente não vai conseguir realizar
aquilo que a gente aquilo que a gente
pretende na vida
então essa é essa e se esse modo de vida
um modo simples um modo onde a gente vai
fazer desse despojando daquilo que nos
foi colocado à disposição dos conceitos
metais que nos foram colocados e
entrando em contato com nossa
profundidade e quando essa real cura
eu sei que muitas vezes as pessoas
precisam adoecer para poder despertar
eu sei disso também são muitas pessoas
precisam às vezes fazer cortes no
próprio corpo fazer cirurgias e se faz
parte do próprio da própria existência
daquela pessoa para que ela possa e
compreender o sentido está na terra
sentido de estar vivo se deve estar vivo
significa a pulsação da vida em si
significa aquilo que você tem de mais
sagrado aqui
esse é o sentido da vida e dentro do
xamanismo que eu pratico eu sou devota
da deusa mãe
adeus à mãe como entidade feminina adeus
à mãe aquela que tem mil faces adeus à
mãe aquela que se apresenta dentro de
uma intuição profunda dentro de uma
compreensão profunda e dentro de
acolhimento da resistência seja aquele
que for essa é tanto homem quanto a
mulher de adeus à mãe se porque isso é
intuitivo isso é de compreensão eu
trabalho nessa renovação profunda dela
ea todo tempo eu peço a ajuda cada vez
mais vejo as mil faces de alencar
a ser que chega à terra mirim em cada
ser que o trabalho e cada ser que eu
ando por aí e vejo sei que a face do
divino em cada um embora a gente não
compreenda que a gente tem uma fácil
divina mas nós somos o divino
nós temos a faixa de renda em cada um
então se a gente puder compreender que
quando a gente olha um outro agente tá
olhando deus e deusa a gente começa a se
diluir a confiar na resistência a
confiar nesse outro que chega a confiar
nesse outro que acolhe
dentro desse trabalho todo esse nesse
processo que eu vivo que não é não digo
a vocês que não é uma coisa fácil de
forma nenhuma que exige também muito e
exige despojado preconceitos que eu
também tenho me deseja colher minhas
sombras que eu também tenho eu sempre
digo às pessoas que a luz é tão perfeita
que ela corre perfeito
quando você ouvir alguém exigir vocês a
perfeição essa pessoa então te ama
porque trabalhar é preciso acolher a
imperfeição ea imperfeição é do ser
humano
nós vamos aqui no aprendizado para nos
tornarmos cada vez mais refinados cada
vez mais conscientes do nosso processo
aqui por exemplo ou símbolo da deusa mãe
é o símbolo do cálice aquele que acolhe
vocês sabem que existe dois símbolos
importantes no xamanismo importante que
é o cálice estada o caso como algo
feminino ea espada como algo masculino
os dois juntos se interpenetram para
formar uma nova existência para formar
um novo c
então é preciso que ao mesmo tempo mesmo
do meu gêneros e feminino eu possa ser
também uma espada e ao mesmo tempo ser
um cálice e assim eu me torne uma
unidade sabendo que quanto mais a separo
quanto mais eu divido - inteiros o mais
frágil é você
quanto mais eu mostro minha
vulnerabilidade que não é uma fraqueza é
vulnerável
idade quanto mais o moncho mas eu posso
ser eu mesma mas as pessoas podem
acolher começou então a gente tem muito
medo de nossas vulnerabilidades mas
porque têm medo das vulnerabilidades
então pra isso dentro do xamanismo
prático a gente tem vários ritos
nós utilizamos de vários ritos seja o
rito da cabana da purificação onde você
entra significado entrar no útero da mãe
terra e sairá renascido
nós temos o rito da busca da visão onde
você vai sozinho fazer seu círculo de
busca da visão se senta ali dentro e
passar duas noites e três dias os seis
noites sete dias sem comer e sem beber
nada mas com você dentro de você
escutando seu interior quando você sai
dali você só renascido isso é um mito se
vocês lerem a bíblia por exemplo se
desentenderem da caminhada crítica
quando ele foi o deserto aquele era a
busca da visão e passou 40 dias e 40
noites na busca da lesão ele enfrentou
os demônios dele não era o demônio
externo não era satanás como a igreja
prega era o próprio demônio interior a
gente própria que se tenta todos os
demônios também nós todos os santos
estão em nós ea gente precisa cada vez
mais conhecê los pra gente poder saber
transitar sem ser manipulado por tantar
portanto o conceito portanto preconceito
por tanta coisa que nos coloca na cabeça
e não nos deixam caminhar cada vez mais
eu tenho visto é como um como um
processo existencial
nós também nos tornarmos seres além de
tudo conscientes e seres políticos
dentro do xamanismo que a gente trabalha
uma ventania mirim
existe um movimento político cidadão das
pessoas precisam exercer o seu lado de
força o seu lado direito o seu lado de
exigir que a mãe terra e seus direitos
sejam realmente respeitados
a mãe terra se a gente diz respeito à
mãe terra
a gente diz respeitando a gente mesmo
porque a gente se alimenta de onde as
coisas vem de onde
da mãe terra então é importante que cada
vez mais esse processo seja feito dentro
de um respeito político devido respeito
ao cidadão um de cada vez mais a gente
tem de ter um movimento cada vez mais
nem te união e colaboração em cooperação
com vocês estão fazendo aqui agora no
processo colaborativo é levar essa
mensagem para o mundo pra essa mensagem
para as pessoas
eu agradeço muito a vocês por essa
oportunidade e estou muito feliz por
poder tá falando daquilo que eu acredito
naquilo que eu sinto e daquilo que eu
vivo há coerência o meu pensamento a
minha fala e ameaçam a minha fala não é
um discurso
a minha fala é uma palavra ea palavra é
uma honra